hi guys I'm Greg and I'm dan dan from
the gaming channel that cyber channel
here today because I don't really game
ever but he does and a lot of people
have asked me to watch The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild Nintendo switch
presentations when he said it in trailer
been asking for like over a week now
he's the only friend who was willing to
come by after as a whole busy schedule
but I'm going to prolong this reactions
a little bit longer just so I can give a
shout out today's sponsor what are
blocks right here these guys normally do
on boxing videos get surprised over
stuff but I kind of know about today's
theme is fantasy what they're like Luke
rate in the sense that you order [ __ ] in
a box once a month you get surprises
everyone well it comes in a green box
comes in a green box and kind of
different stuff fantasy we had the
Futurama pop head oh my god BeeZee POTUS
is so cool I love fry a lot this is
funny funny this Harry Potter sticker oh
my god lord of the rings' oil put put on
your laps on it on Lord of the Rings
what Lord of the Rings men are the best
if this shirt is pretty [ __ ] sweet I
will definitely be rocking this you're
an upcoming video look at that that's
got FRA link Harry Potter and three dams
three day three dam be wrapping a [ __ ]
calling you
briea cheese which is anyway guys yeah
that's the 1up box for a month of
promotes a fantasy there's a referral
link in the description box I really do
like a lot of you because you go into my
bedroom sure all you guys come to my
bedroom one day come on let's go
I really do store all these things I
love them I love all the toys and if I
don't like something I give it away to
some homeless kid I know plenty of those
too why'd you look at me when you said
that because I know you're struggling to
not be homeless right now I have a home
okay
images on YouTube you have to maintain I
have a hoe all right let's probably
watch this guy's watch this and I'm like
I don't play games
dan he's a gamer I'm here to provide the
UK he's played all the Zelda games right
all the main consoles there's a few
portable ones I haven't finished yet
let's go technical about it do they want
to know I played ocarina of time that
camp yeah argue argue to be the best
I think links to pasture will not get
there
it's so refreshing to see me intend Oh
make a really really crooked game like
this
Rinaldo game would be good
in their report yeah that's a civic
outfit
oh my god weirdo Boggs is adorable
a wolf pack's
[Music]
neither man game look math I said I
still can't get over the fact that this
is a Zelda game like every single time
I'm just like we're doing this
the history of the royal family of
hiring is also the history of the
calamity gather a primal evil that has
been do over the ages
[Music]
what happened and I would open with it
what would assume
Wow hi that's what I was excited there
you go yeah
but look on your face tells me you were
so crazy hearing voice acting in a Salva
game like you are now ready ready to
hear what happened 100 years ago
yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
put [ __ ] snapping man I mean I was
going to buy the game but all my five
copies now
[Music]
does link have a voice yeah goes back
[Music]
house rear hearings Elvis II do didn't
you free I opened them we're to use
again yeah I think if we get your
attention
that's early state the whole thing is
just so weird to hear all of like
characters that have normally been like
a grunt and then tactics yeah and now
it's fun Lee a grunt Advent speaking I
wasn't expecting the scope to be like
that massively epic yeah that's very
appealing and very appealing you know I
often see trailers runner I'm like I am
I'm I play this game and I usually don't
so I'm not going to say I will
definitely play this game but you are
more like but I'm a little only like
we're you know if I get invited over to
play a game with you I might put this
one on there's all the games you could
be Noah day oh yeah totally
it's a one day that's a single episode
every trailer that they come out like
first scene like just how big the next
Delta was going to be when they first
announced it seeing gameplay of it and
how big the environment actually is yeah
and then now being able to see how much
like emotion and like voice acting acts
at like adds a lot totally it totally
does and not that any of the previous
Zelda's ever felt like the motionless
there's definitely a lot of motion in
there as a human being I am like I have
more empathy for some like net character
that talks
well sometimes to a voice I can make or
break a game because it could either be
really cheesy or it could make it more
effective yeah and I feel like it'll be
pretty effective here well and the big
thing is is like if you have someone
crying if you don't hit like the next
button to move on with the conversation
then it's just yeah exactly
bobbing there and then like the moment
where
I'm assuming that Zelda they'll say like
it might not be Zelda but it's most
likely Zelda the same I could trying to
emotionally cook you this time yeah and
everything about it's great
I really admire the effects of it
because it's not trying to do that thing
we're alike which I make this look as
realistic as possible like yeah if
anything they're just making like really
advanced animation you know like you you
it feels like an animated movie yeah it
doesn't feel what you know what I mean
like when they try to like oh it's
making these human characters look as
human as possible in real life but like
no they're gonna just stick with the
anime look as much as possible Nintendo
has always been done a really good job
with keeping the more cartoony like
aesthetic while still making it look
beautiful all the way through and this
is another great example Java look hot I
knew you I knew you were gonna say that
he does she was beautiful yes she does
but I just like the moment she turned
around and looked I was like Greg's
gonna say she looked she looked hot she
reminds me of Rihanna white doesn't she
come on so guys you get that and I have
a girlfriend
oh my god come on you [ __ ] Briana why
planar why yeah I'm a little Briana
white now simple as that
oh my god it just kind of look like her
it looks a lot like her well I mean
Briana doesn't have giant anime eyes
that's her fault that trend you had one
problem with Rihanna States dr. G yeah
we're gonna we're a doctor next time
she's like yeah so what the [ __ ] up was
and I know with that uh that react to
the whole grand scope of everything like
you see these shops where you're like
here's everything you can explore like
that is a massive open world they got
going on it's not just like here's a
giant world cinematic where yeah right
but you're confined to huge the only one
kind of what yeah I hate any games
really you can't go past a certain point
but like it looks like you can go pretty
much anywhere in this game they were
saying is like every mountain that you
can see you can go to what's the story
is the same one I think same story again
I don't know I think you got a lot of
trouble game
comes along I mean Hyrule basically
[ __ ] I will always [ __ ] linking to
stop trying to save a damn thank you
what you got figure it I figure I've
been wanting to [ __ ] it out alright the
only thing I do know is that it opens
with linked in some hibernation chamber
sting okay and then he wakes up and has
to do stuff and what Zelda wasn't a
hibernation you know I felt it wasn't in
the gameplay I saw this is the first
time in that [ __ ] is this the first time
we've seen her it might be Danna bring
you here to know these things bring you
here educated geez man I put you my
reputation on the line but bringing you
here I'm a solid replicate you really
need to reach thank you very often
everything looks great about it I'm sure
gamle playing a lot of [ __ ] less
plays on this damn thing if anything
definitely gonna do a video on it doing
a let's play on this would just take me
all year oh whatever
did you can play this game like two
hours oh right this is just like what it
was like easy highlight montage man
record for two hours put it into a three
minute video yeah no problem right QT
yang just so I can go right the whole
time simple everything we just saw is a
cinema I know the way games are I'm
gonna do it only right run where all I
can only go right alright guys well you
can subscribe to this channel if you
want to dan you subscribe to him though
alright only send me if you actually
want to subscribe but Dan you don't have
a door you should that cyber channel
that cyber got Instagram and Twitter you
and he's also going to be streaming some
videos I don't know when auntie Jean
Wednesdays at 3:30 on youtube.com slash
user slash games wow they got gay got
game yeah kid they got journey they have
so many going to go there watch him play
some games check out more of his content